Hi there. Welcome back for another interview with a cast member from the paper. And we should probably tell you we watch the first four episodes. We have watched them. It's so good. It's really good. It's very hard not to say more, but we are not allowed. I think people are going to be happy. I really do. I agree. I think it feels like the office. Like it's very clear that this is the same universe. Okay, that's all I think we can say. Yeah, we've probably said too much. Well, wait, I do want to say one more thing. Okay. I want to say that we are not sponsored by Peacock or NBC. Yeah, no, we are not. I just want to say that because I just want people to know this is not an ad. For Peacock or NBC.
大家好。欢迎再次收听我们对《The Paper》剧组演员的采访。我们大概应该告诉大家，我们已经看过前四集了。我们确实看过了。真的太棒了。非常棒。要忍住不说更多内容其实挺难的，但我们不能剧透。我觉得大家一定会喜欢的。我真的这么觉得。我同意。我觉得它很有《The Office》的感觉。就好像非常清楚这和它是同一个宇宙。好吧，我想我们只能说这么多了。是的，我们可能说得太多了。等等，我确实还想说一件事。好吧。我想说的是，我们没有接受 Peacock 或 NBC 的赞助。对，没有，我们真的没有。我只是想说这个，因为我只想让大家知道这不是广告。为 Peacock 或 NBC 做的广告。
Correct. Yeah, basically, here's what happened. Greg invited Jenna and I to visit the set and to meet the cast, and he shared with us some of our old crew was there. We couldn't wait. And Greg has always been amazing to office. ladies. He's a huge supporter of the show. And we went and went to the set. And then he offered us an early sneak peek of the paper pilot and said maybe if we liked it, we could break it down
没错。基本上，事情是这样的。格雷格（Greg）邀请我和珍娜去参观片场并见见演员们，他还跟我们分享说我们以前的一些剧组工作人员也在那儿。我们迫不及待。而且格雷格对《Office Ladies》一直都太好了。他是这部剧的超级支持者。然后我们去了，去了片场。接着他主动让我们提前先睹为快了《The Paper》的试播集，并说如果我们喜欢的话，也许可以剖析一下
because he said he's a huge fan of how we break down episodes. And so it all came together really organically. And I'm so glad we got to do this. Me too. And it just, it meant so much to me that Greg trusts us. Yes. With his new baby, basically, you know? Yeah. And I'm I loved it. Greg, you're going to hear. Yes, you are. We loved it. You know, lady, I do think that the rest of the cast is a little jealous that we got to see it early. I do.
因为他说他是我们剖析剧集方式的超级粉丝。所以这一切结合得非常自然。我很高兴我们能做这件事。我也是。而且这意味着对我来说意义重大，格雷格信任我们。是的。基本上就像信任他的新宝宝一样，你知道吗？是的。我很喜欢。格雷格，你会听到的。是的，你会的。我们太喜欢了。你知道吗，女士，我觉得其他演员其实有点嫉妒我们能提前看到。真的。
I do. And I maybe am lording it over their heads a little bit. Oh, yeah. Did you tease Rain on your lunch? Were you like rain? Guess what? Yes, I got to see it and you didn't. I literally did.
确实如此。而且我可能在他们面前稍微显摆了一下。哦，真的吗？你在午饭时逗雷恩（Rainn）了吗？你有没有对雷恩说：“雷恩，你猜怎么着？对，我看到了，而你没有。”我真的是这么做的。
I did. I had lunch with the rain and I told him that I got to see it. And then I wouldn't tell him anything. Oh, my gosh. I bet that made him crazy. Well, listen, we are really excited because today we are sharing our interview with Sabrina Impetitore. You might know her from season two of the White Lotus. She's fantastic.
我真的这么做了。我和雷恩一起吃午饭，我告诉他我看到了。然后我什么都不肯告诉他。哦，天哪。我敢打赌这把他急疯了。好吧，听着，我们非常兴奋，因为今天我们要分享对萨布里纳·因帕奇亚托雷（Sabrina Impacciatore）的采访。大家可能在《白莲花度假村》第二季中认识她。她太棒了。
And she is phenomenal in the paper. And her story of how she got her role on the paper is amazing. While we were talking to her, they actually called her to set during the interview. But I could have kept talking to her for an hour. Truly, I like want to go on a road trip with her and just hear her talk. Same. I want to know even more things. Yeah. All right. Well, without further delay, here is our interview with Sabrina Impechatory. Well, it is so exciting to get to talk to you. Will you tell us your name and your character name?
而且她在《The Paper》里的表现无与伦比。她获得《The Paper》角色的故事太神奇了。我们在跟她聊的时候，他们在采访期间竟然临时叫她去片场。但我其实可以跟她再聊一个小时。真的，我很想跟她一起去公路旅行，就听她说话就行。我也是。我还想知道更多的事情。好吧。事不宜迟，这就是我们对萨布里纳·因帕奇亚托雷的采访。能跟您聊聊真是太令人兴奋了。能告诉我们您的名字和您扮演的角色的名字吗？
Yes. All right, my name is Sabrina Impacchatorre and my character's name is Esmeralda Grand. Can you tell us a little bit about what your character's story in the show is? is. Oh my God. I have no idea. What does she do? What does she do in her job? What doesn't she do, I would say, because she does everything she can to just try to stay where she is. This is kind of crazy character. Like she could do anything. She, to me, she's someone that needs to survive and so but for her to survive it's a very personal concept you know so every time she feels threatened by something she uses anything she can even the worst things
好的。我的名字是萨布里纳·因帕奇亚托雷，我角色的名字是埃斯梅拉达·格兰德（Esmeralda Grand）。您能给我们稍微讲讲您的角色在剧中的故事吗？哦，天哪。我完全不知道。她做些什么？她在工作中做些什么？我得说，有什么是她不做的呢，因为她为了留在自己现在的位置上，什么都做得出来。这是一个有点疯狂的角色。就像她什么都能干。对我来说，她是一个需要生存下去的人，所以对她而言，生存是一个非常个人的概念，你知道吗？所以每当她觉得受到某种事物的威胁时，她就会利用她能利用的一切，甚至是世上最糟糕的手段
possible just to protect herself so i see her like a little wild animal And then she's the only Italian. She moved here and she doesn't want to leave. Like she wants just to be here and keep living in this country. And she works in this office, but she could actually do anything else because she's not a real journalist. So she is just someone that pretends to be anything. because she just has to make it. Are you the only actual reporter at the paper?
来保护自己，所以我把她看作是一只小野兽。而且她是唯一的意大利人。她搬到了这里，并且不想离开。她只想留在这里，继续在这个国家生活。她在这个办公室工作，但她其实可以做任何其他事情，因为她不是真正的记者。所以她只是一个假装成任何角色的人。因为她必须设法混下去。你是《The Paper》里唯一真正的记者吗？
Is that your job? Not really. Like, my job was to be the editor-in-chief of TTT Online. But then, and she was very happy about this, very proud. And then this guy arrives, like they knew. And she is literally kicked out of her office. So she struggles a lot because of that. And then she just tries to find her space in this new, you know,
那是你的工作吗？其实不是。我的工作是担任 TTT Online 的总编辑。然后，她对此感到非常高兴，非常骄傲。接着这个家伙来了，就像他们认识的一样。而她字面意义上被赶出了自己的办公室。所以她为此挣扎了很久。然后她只是试图在这个新的，你知道的
in this new hierarchy. And so of course she is the one that wants always to be in front. Like she's also, to me, this is something that, because I've been creating this character with Greg and Michael and all the other writers. Now, I was very, very inspired by, already by the sides during the audition. And so then I decided to, I don't know, I didn't decide. Things just arrived. So to me, somehow she thinks that through this documentary,
在这个新的等级制度中找到自己的位置。所以理所当然地，她总是那个想冲在最前面的人。对我来说这也是，因为我和格雷格、迈克尔还有所有其他编剧一起塑造这个角色。当时，我在试镜时就已经深受台词的启发了。所以后来我决定，我不知道，我并没有刻意决定。事情就那么自然而然地发生了。所以对我来说，不知何故，她认为通过这部纪录片
one day maybe she could become a star. So she also uses the camera to suggest that idea. That's why I decided to have this kind of hair like a diva from the 40s to suggest, hey, look at me. I'm a superstar too. And so she acts like a star. She behaves like a star. She thinks big.
也许有一天她能成为明星。所以她也利用镜头来暗示那个想法。这就是为什么我决定留这种40年代红星的发型来暗示：嘿，看我。我也是个超级巨星。所以她表现得像个明星。她的举止像个明星。她胸怀大志。
She is big. The way she dresses, the way she acts, she's also very manipulative. She uses everything, very manipulative. What a fun character. I love her. I can't wait to watch this. You know, it reminds me a lot of how Michael Scott loved the camera, right? And Andy, he thought he was going to be a big star.
她很大牌。她穿衣服的方式，她行事的方式，她也非常有操纵欲。她利用一切，非常擅长操纵。多么有趣的性格。我太喜欢她了。我迫不及待想看这部剧了。你知道的，这让我想起了迈克尔·斯科特（Michael Scott）是多么热爱镜头，对吧？还有安迪（Andy），他以为自己会成为超级巨星。
He was very excited when the documentary airs. So I sort of see a little bit of that theme. Can you tell us about the audition? your process and how you got your job on the paper? Yes, of course. So that was, I have to be short because it's a long story, but I was shooting a movie in Cape Town. I was in Cape Town, South Africa since three months, part away from home and everything. And I am literally entering in the flight, going back to Italy. And I got a call from my agent from L.A. She said, Sabrina, did you read the email?
纪录片播出时他非常兴奋。所以我某种程度上看到了类似的主题。你能跟我们讲讲试镜的过程，以及你是如何得到《The Paper》的工作的吗？可以，当然。所以那是——我得长话短说，因为这故事很长——当时我正在开普敦拍电影。我在南非开普敦待了三个月，远离家乡和一切。而我当时正准备登机回意大利。我接到了来自洛杉矶经纪人的电话。她说：“萨布里纳，你看了邮件吗？”
I said, no, what email? I was packaging. I was saying goodbye to the crew. She had, do you have to read this email right now? But I am almost flying. So I read the email and there was the call for this audition. And they gave me 24 hours to prepare 11 pages in English. 24 hours was exactly the time of the flight back to Italy.
我说：“没有，什么邮件？”我当时在打包行李。我在跟剧组告别。她说：“你现在必须立刻看这封邮件。”“可是我马上就要起飞了。”所以我看了邮件，里面有这个试镜的通知。他们给了我24小时用英语准备11页纸。24小时正好是我飞回意大利的飞行时间。
But me, I felt I cannot do an audition just coming out of the flight after. And so I was telling my agent, please, please, try to get some time more. How can I learn these things? I'm flying. I'm tired. I'm upset. And she said, I don't know if I can make it. I'll write you.
但我觉得，刚下飞机我根本没办法马上进行试镜。所以我对经纪人说：“求求你，求求你，试着争取多一点时间。我怎么背得下这些东西？我在飞机上。我很累。我很沮丧。”她说：“我不知道能不能办到。我一会儿写信给你。”
So now just go. So I flow for 10 hours. And then I arrive in Doha. I can't remember. I opened my email and she wrote me we got one day more so I was very excited
所以现在你快上机吧。于是我飞了10个小时。然后我到达多哈。我不记得了。我打开邮件，她写道我们多争取到了一天时间，所以我非常兴奋
but still like I can't make it like this is very long to learn 11 pages of monologues but I read this side and I felt in love you know it's like
但还是觉得“我搞不定啊，背11页的独白实在太长了”。不过我读了这些台词剧本，然后我就恋爱了，你知道的，就好像
love at first side I was like oh my God this is too brilliant this is too funny and guess what? I had never saw the office in my life.
一见钟情。我当时想：“天哪，这太才华横溢了，这太有趣了。”你猜怎么着？我这辈子从来没看过《Office》。
I didn't know about this show. I was the only one on this planet that hadn't seen this show. So the first two episodes I saw them on the flight from Cape Town to Rome.
我不知道这部剧。我是这个星球上唯一一个没看过这部剧的人。所以我看的前两集是在从开普敦飞往罗马的飞机上看的。
And I felt like, oh my God, what a weird project. That doesn't look like anything familiar. That's so weird. And this acting is so believable. It looks really like and the light is so bad. I'm going to be so ugly. That was the main concern. So then I arrived in Rome after three months. I don't see my mom and nothing. But I call my mom and said, Mom, forget about me. Have an audition tomorrow. So we can't see. We can't. So I spend all night long to study the sides? I find an American girl. It's a long story that she comes to my place
我觉得：“天哪，这是什么奇怪的项目。看起来一点都不熟悉。太奇怪了。而且这演技太逼真了。看起来真的很像，而且光线太差了。我会显得好丑啊。”那是我的主要担忧。然后我回到罗马，已经离开三个月了。我没见到我妈什么的。但我给我妈打电话说：“妈，先别管我了。我明天有个试镜。所以我们不能见。我们不行。”所以我通宵都在研究剧本？我找了一个美国女孩——这话说来话长——她来到我家
and we study, study, study, study, study. And then I do this Zoom meeting with all my luggage just looking at me, you know, the luggage I couldn't touch the luggage. I couldn't open that. They were there. And I did this Zoom meeting with Greg, with Michael, with the casting director, with the producers. There were six, seven people there. And I said, okay. Let's go. And I forgot all the lines. Of course, the memory was not solid enough. So I started the scenes with the correct lines.
然后我们疯狂地学习、学习、学习、学习。接着我带着周围所有的行李进行了这场 Zoom 面试，你知道的，那些我碰都不能碰的行李。我不能打开行李。它们就在那儿。我和格雷格、迈克尔、选角导演、制片人们一起开了 Zoom 会议。当时大概有六、七个人在那儿。我说：“好吧。开始吧。”然后我把所有台词都忘了。当然，记忆不够扎实。所以我用正确的台词开始了场景。
But after a couple of lines, I completely invented everything else. So I was improvising, improvising, improvising, and I didn't hear a sound. So I said, this is going very bad. But it's okay, I'll keep going. I kept going for 40 minutes, I think. 45 minutes. And then they said, stop. And they all appeared.
但说了几句之后，我完全即兴发挥了剩下的部分。所以我一直在即兴发挥、即兴发挥、即兴发挥，而我什么声音都没听到。所以我心想：“这下糟透了。”不过没关系，我继续演。我想我大概持续了40分钟。45分钟。然后他们说：“停。”接着他们全都露面了。
I had understood that they had mute themselves. They said, Sabrina, you really made us laugh a lot. But you didn't remember nothing. And they said, could you do this again in two days? What the fuck? Oh my God. I said, really? Like after three months, I'm not, okay, so two days after, I did this again,
我这才明白他们之前一直处于静音状态。他们说：“萨布里纳，你真的把我们逗得哈哈大笑。但你什么台词都没记住。”然后他们说：“你能在两天后再试一次吗？”搞什么鬼？哦，天哪。我说：“真的吗？就像在三个月之后，我没……好吧。”所以在两天后，我又试了一次
but with all the memory and everything, and actually I sent a self-tape with all the scenes. I was very inspired, like I was very inspired. I felt like I was a channel and things were just arriving and I was having so much fun in that audition. And then I sent it and then for a month, I don't hear from anybody. so I thought okay it's it's not working I was very sad because in the meanwhile I was watching the office and I was like oh my god this project is the most brilliant project I've seen it was so incredibly intelligent and real funny you know when you when you laugh you laugh with your brain with your heart with
但这次记熟了所有台词，各方面都准备好了。实际上我发了一个包含所有场景的自录试镜带。我非常有灵感，真的很有灵感。我觉得自己就像一个通道，灵感源源不断地涌来，我在那次试镜中玩得太开心了。然后我发了过去，接着有一个月，我没有收到任何人的消息。所以我想：“好吧，没戏了。”我非常伤心，因为与此同时我一直在看《Office》，心想：“天哪，这个项目是我见过最才华横溢的项目。它是如此不可思议地聪明、真实又有趣。”你知道，当你笑的时候，是用你的大脑去笑，用你的心去笑，用
your everything you're really loved and um And then, incredibly enough, after one month, I got another role, a big, big role, like a very big important project. So I was very happy because I said, oh, my God. So I was jumping on the air because of this other role. Like I was crying because it was really something I loved. And so it was like midnight because from Italy to America. It was midnight and all my team called me from the US, Sabrina, you got it. that role wow so i have fun i drink with all my friends we celebrate we toss blah blah blah then i go back home
你的全身心去笑，你是真的在笑。然后，难以置信的是，一个月后，我得到了另一个角色，一个非常非常大的角色，一个非常非常重要的大项目。所以我非常高兴，因为我想：“哦，天哪。”我因为这个角色高兴得手舞足蹈。我甚至哭了，因为这真的是我非常喜欢的东西。当时大概是半夜，因为意大利和美国有时差。那是半夜，我所有的美国团队成员都打电话给我：“萨布里纳，你拿下了那个角色。”哇。所以我很开心，我和所有的朋友喝酒、庆祝、干杯等等。然后我回家
it's four o'clock a am and i feel beep beep from my team sabrina you also got the roll from the oh in the same day you found out in the same day day oh my goodness that was actually the same night right right right so that was so crazy I couldn't sleep, of course. I was in my back like, like, what's happening? What am I doing? What's going to happen? What can I do?
已经是凌晨四点了，我听到我的团队发来“哔哔”的提示音：“萨布里纳，你还拿下了那部剧的角色……”在同一天！你在同一天知道了！哦天哪。其实那是同一天晚上，对吧？对，对，对。所以太疯狂了。我当然睡不着。我躺在床上想：这到底是怎么回事？我在干什么？接下来会发生什么？我该怎么办？
So I had just a couple of days to take a decision. And I was desperate, really. You had to choose between the two. You couldn't do both. No, we couldn't do both. They were exactly. And there were two things that I really loved. So I was really, really, really desperate, to be honest.
所以我只有几天时间来做决定。我当时真的很绝望，真的。你不得不在两者之间做出选择。你不能两个都接。对，我们不能两个都接。它们正好是。这两件事我都非常喜欢。所以说实话，我当时真的、真的很绝望。
You want to know the truth? when I took the decision, I cried for six hours. And it was a long time I wasn't crying. But I cried for six hours because I thought, this is how my life crazy. My crazy life is. I have to say no to something that is unbelievable to me because some other thing that is unbelievable is happening.
你想知道真相吗？当我做出决定的时候，我哭了六个小时。我已经很久没有哭过了。但我哭了六个小时，因为我想，我的生活就是这样疯狂。我疯狂的生活就是这样。我不得不对一个对我来说难以置信的机会说不，因为另一个同样难以置信的事情正在发生。
And then Greg and Michael called me. I will never forget that call. because at first they had asked me Sabrina can you learn an American accent and me perfectly lying I said of course I can but I was so scared that said how can I learn an American accent
然后格雷格和迈克尔给我打了电话。我永远不会忘记那个电话。因为一开始他们问我：“萨布里纳，你能学会美式口音吗？”而我厚着脸皮完美地撒了谎，我说：“当然可以。”但我其实吓坏了，心想：“我怎么可能把美式口音学得……”
so fastly that then they called me they said Sabrina after watching your audition we cannot imagine any other actor actress doing this role and we also love your accent it's so charming
学得那么快？结果他们打电话对我说：“萨布里纳，看完你的试镜后，我们无法想象有任何其他男演员或女演员能演这个角色。而且我们也喜欢你的口音，太迷人了。”
God take it take it take it and this is how it happened well i what a story and you know this is one of the great things about working with gregg daniels is that he attaches to a performer to an actor and he really respects the craft of the actor and he wants to draw parts of you into the character that he had in mind and there's such a collaboration there and you get to be be a part of, you know, you said you felt like you were channeling something. And Greg is, he's humble enough to invite that kind of collaboration. Yeah, he loves creative collaboration. I always felt like we were building something together. You know, I didn't have just this boss
天哪，接下它，接下它，接下它。事情就是这样发生的。哇，真是个传奇的故事。你知道，和格雷格·丹尼尔斯（Greg Daniels）合作的伟大之处之一，就是他会对表演者、对演员产生一种黏着力，他非常尊重演员的表演艺术，他想把你的特质融入到他构思的角色中。那是一种真正的合作，而且你能够参与其中。你知道的，你刚才说你觉得自己在传递某种能量。而格雷格足够谦逊，能邀请这种合作。是的，他热爱创造性的合作。我一直觉得我们是在一起建造某些东西。你知道的，我面对的不是那种只会
telling me, your characters does this and you do this. It was a conversation and you're part of that. Oh, what a great story. Oh, my gosh. This is an ad by BetterHelp. You know, it feels like nowadays there's advice for just about everything. It's like, do you write in your journal, do you do, I don't know, cleanses or the cold plunge or, you know, what helps you get through the day? What helps you get through stressful moments? Mm-hmm. For me, it's talking it out. Mm-hmm. Well, there can be a lot of information overload about mental health and wellness, and it can be a struggle to know what's true and what actions to take these days. So you might think about using a trusted resource and talking to live therapists through BetterHelp. It has an app store rating of 4.9 out of 5 based on over 1.7 million client reviews. As the largest online therapy provider in the world, BetterHelp can provide access.
对我说“你的角色是这样的，你得这么演”的老板。这是一场对话，而你是其中的一部分。哦，多棒的故事啊。哦，天哪。这是一个来自 Better Help 的广告。你知道，感觉现在不管什么事都有人在给你提建议。就像，你会写日记吗？你会做，我不知道，排毒疗法、冷水浴，或者，你知道的，什么能帮你度过难关？什么能帮你应对压力时刻？嗯。对我和来说，是把心事说出来。嗯。关于心理健康和保健，现在可能会有大量的过载信息，要想知道什么是真的、该采取什么行动可能会很挣扎。所以你可以考虑使用一个值得信赖的资源，通过 Better Help 与真人治疗师交流。它在应用商店里获得了4.9星的高分（满分5分），这基于超过170万客户的评价。作为全球最大的在线治疗提供商，Better Help 可以为你提供
to mental health professionals with a diverse variety of expertise. Talk it out with BetterHelp. Our listeners get 10% off their first month at BetterHelp.com slash office ladies. That's BetterHelp-H-E-L-P.com slash office ladies. Get to Toronto's main venues like Budweiser Stage and the new Roger Stadium with Go Transit. Thanks to Go Transit's special online e-ticket fairs,
具备各种多元专业知识的心理健康专业人员。通过 Better Help 把心事说出来。我们的听众在 BetterHelp.com/officeladies 首月可享 9 折优惠。网址是 BetterHelp-H-E-L-P.com/officeladies。乘坐 Go Transit 前往多伦多各大主要场所，如百威舞台（Budweiser Stage）和全新的罗杰斯体育场（Rogers Stadium）。多亏了 Go Transit 推出的在线电子车票特惠活动
a $10 one-day weekend pass offers unlimited travel on any weekend day or holiday anywhere along the go network and the weekday group passes offer the same weekday travel flexibility across the network starting at $30 for two people and up to $60 for a group of five buy your online go pass ahead of the show at go transit.com slash tickets what has it been like now working on the show a lot of girls when I got this role then of course I couldn't sleep for many weeks because I was very scared. I was terrified because the quality of the acting was so high level. I said, I cannot, I will never join that level.
10美元的一日周末通票可在任何周末或节假日期间在 Go 网络沿线的任意地点提供无限次搭乘服务，而工作日团体通票则在整个网络中提供同样灵活的工作日出行方式，两人起价30美元，五人团体最高60美元。请在演出前于 gotransit.com/tickets 购买您的在线 Go 通票。现在参与这部剧的工作是什么感觉？很多女孩在接到这个角色后，当然有好多周都睡不着觉，因为我非常害怕。我被吓坏了，因为这里的演技水准实在太高了。我说：“我做不到，我永远也达不到那个水平。”
And watching Steve Carrell's work, for example, to me was epiphonic. I thought, this guy is one of the biggest artists on this planet because he's able to make me laugh in a very sophisticated way and everything is in his eyes. He has this innocence and there was something really incredible about him. So because I believe in energies and everything, I got to know that he was playing Uncle Banya in New York in Broadway. And I took a flight to go to meet him from Rome. I got a flight to see the show.
例如，看着史蒂夫·卡瑞尔（Steve Carell）的作品，对我来说就像是顿悟。我觉得，这家伙是这个星球上最伟大的艺术家之一，因为他能以一种非常sophisticated（老练/精妙）的方式让我笑出来，而且一切都在他的眼神里。他有一种天真感，他身上有些东西真的非常不可思议。所以因为我相信能量之类的东西，我得知他当时正在纽约百货百老汇（Broadway）出演《万尼亚舅舅》（Uncle Vanya）。我买了一张从罗马飞去见他的机票。我买机票去看演出。
I bought tickets. And then I wrote to Greg. I said, Greg, I'm going to see Uncle Vanya. I want to meet Steve Carell. I want to be blessed by him. And that's what happened. So I arrived to Broadway. I saw this incredible show.
我买票去了。然后我写信给格雷格。我说：“格雷格，我要去看《万尼亚舅舅》了。我想见史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。我想得到他的祝福。”事情就是这样发生的。于是我来到了百老汇。我看了这部不可思议的演出。
He was brilliant. I couldn't believe that he was on stage playing Uncle Vana in such a different way. So original, so far away from the. the character in the office and then I went to the green room and he was the sweetest man ever and so humble. And he was telling me the most sweet things like you are going to crush it. You're going to have so much fun. Greg is the bad. So it was really a blessing to me. I felt so blessed. Well, you know, right after I got my role on the office, I had the opportunity to go to dinner with Peter Boyle, who is, you know, famous comedic actor. He had been on Everybody
他太出色了。我简直不敢相信他在舞台上以如此截然不同的方式饰演万尼亚舅舅。那么原创，距离《Office》里的角色那么遥远。然后我去了后台休息室，他是全世界最温柔的男士，而且非常谦逊。他对我说了世界上最甜美的话：“你会大获成功的。你会玩得很开心的。格雷格太棒了。”所以这对我来说真的是一种祝福。我觉得自己太受眷顾了。你知道，就在我得到《Office》的角色后不久，我有机会和彼得·博伊尔（Peter Boyle）共进晚餐，他是一位著名的喜剧演员，你知道的。他曾出演过《人人都爱雷蒙德》（Everybody Loves Raymond），我非常喜欢他。我记得他看着我，然后他说，嗯，他说：“好吧，我在《人人都爱雷蒙德》的日子，嗯，已经画上了句号。现在，当你开启这段旅程时，我希望能把那种能量传递给你。”
Loves Raymond, and I loved him so much. And I remember he looked at me and he said, um, he said, well, my time on everybody loves Raymond, uh, has come to an end. And I would like to, um, send that energy your way now as you start your journey. as I finished my journey and you start the journey, I hope that you will have the success and the good times that I experienced. He sort of gave me his blessing, you know? And it was really meaningful to me. And I really held that.
“当我的旅程结束，而你开启旅程时，我希望你能拥有我曾经历过的成功和美好时光。”他算是给了我他的祝福，你知道吗？这对我意义重大。我真的把这份祝福记在心里了。
I thought, oh, my gosh, I felt like we were just, I receive it. And like I was just blessed by Peter Boyle. Yeah. So you totally understand this feeling. Yes. I do, though. I believe in like the just good energy and opening yourself up to it and receiving it. And Jenna knows this story. But when I was a young actor here taking classes, working at a restaurant, you know, I read that Jim Carrey, he went to the top of Mulholland. You know, it looks out over the whole city. And he yelled into the night sky that I'm going to be a big star. I read this. I read this. I don't know if it's true. So I took my friend and I, we went one night, we went up to Mahalo and you could see all the lights of Hollywood. And I wrote out what I was going to say. I was very specific. I looked out into the valley and I yelled very loudly. I said, I am going to be on a hit television show on NBC on Thursday nights. Oh, my God. I'm going to Malland drive tonight. Oh, my God. Isn't that so crazy?
我想，哦，天哪，我觉得我们就好像……我接收到了。就像我得到了彼得·博伊尔的祝福一样。是的，所以你完全理解这种感觉。是的。不过我相信，这只是一种好能量，向它敞开心扉并接受它。珍娜知道这个故事。但当我还是这里的一个年轻演员时，一边上课一边在餐厅打工，你知道的，我读到过吉姆·凯瑞（Jim Carrey）曾去过穆赫兰大道（Mulholland）的顶端。你知道的，那里可以俯瞰整座城市。他在夜空中大喊“我要成为大明星”。我读到过这个。我读到过。我不知道这是不是真的。所以我带上我的朋友，有一天晚上我们去了穆赫兰大道，你可以看到好莱坞所有的灯光。我把我准备说的话写了下来。我非常具体。我望着山谷，大声地喊道：“我要在周四晚上的 NBC 热门电视节目里出演角色！”哦，天哪。我今晚就要去穆赫兰大道。哦，天哪。这难道不是很疯狂吗？
But I believe that. Oh, yeah. I do believe in that. Same. Yeah. So imagine that me, before starting, I also needed the blessing of the ghosts in Chateau Marmont. Oh, yeah. So I decided to go there for two weeks just to get the blessing of those ghosts.
但我相信这一点。哦，是的。我确实相信这个。我也是。所以想象一下，我在开始之前，也需要得到地中海传奇酒店（Chateau Marmont）里那些幽灵的祝福。哦，是的。所以我决定在那里待两周，只为了得到那些幽灵的祝福。
So, you know, I did all the... Everything I could. I was so frightened. Well, I need many blessings here. When the paper is a huge success. I think everyone knows who to thank. It's you. Yes.
所以，你知道的，我做了所有……我能做的一切。我当时太害怕了。好吧，我这里需要很多祝福。《The Paper》大获成功后。我想每个人都知道该感谢谁。就是你。是的。
You did all the things. I'm breaking balls to every possible God, essence, like, entity, ghosts. Yeah. I was wondering, you know, if you would like to, because we have a global audience on our podcast, people from all over the world listen to it. And it's very meaningful to us,
你把能做的都做了。我在对所有可能的上帝、神灵、存在、幽灵“各种死缠烂打”。是的。我在想，你知道的，你是否愿意——因为我们的播客有全球听众，世界各地的人们都在收听。这对我们意义重大
but would you like to say something in a, Italian to your fans in Italy that we can play on our podcast about just this time on the paper. Oh, my. Guys, I don't know what to say. I can say only that it's a great vertigene, a great honor, a great song that is realized. And I'm sure that all the ragazes Italian that have their dreams have to continue to creder to, to all, in general,
但你是否愿意用意大利语对你在意大利的粉丝说些什么，我们可以把这段话放在我们的播客里，关于你在《The Paper》这段时间的感受？哦，天哪。伙计们，我不知道该说什么。我只能说这是一次伟大的晕眩，巨大的荣誉，一个成真的梦想。我确信所有有梦想的意大利年轻人必须继续相信……所有的，总的来说
but the guys Italian me stand in quodden. Well, I know they'll love hearing that and we'll Google
但是意大利的小伙子们……好吧，我知道他们听到这个一定会很高兴，我们会用谷歌
translate it if you want I can translate it very shortly it's just that I don't know what I feel it's a
翻译一下。如果你愿意，我可以简单翻译一下。这只是因为我不知道我的感受是什么，这是一种
it's a vertigo it's the biggest dream coming through and I was wishing that all the Italian girls
眩晕感，是最大的梦想成真。我希望所有怀揣巨大梦想的意大利女孩——因为我知道一个意大利女孩因为我们国家依然存在的诸多问题而要经历多少挣扎。这就是为什么我要把这话献给那些依然应该相信自己梦想并为之奋斗的意大利女孩。
that have a big dream because I know how much an Italian girl can struggle because of so many issues that we still have in our country. So that's why I was dedicating this to the Italian girls that should still believe in their dreams and just go for them.
太棒了。好吧，在我们结束之前，你能跟我们简单讲讲你作为演员的起步经历，以及你是如何走到今天这个位置的吗？
Love that. Well, before we finish up, could you tell us a little bit about your beginnings as an actress and kind of how did you get to this place that you are now? that's why I think this is a miracle because yeah I think I have to go you have to go you have to go do your job your dream job this was so lovely you blessed by you girls that was the best last year it was oh my god I can't wait to see you again girls that was very beautiful oh yes oh we'll come back you are two geniuses and I feel so honored to meet you. Thank you for your incredible, inspiring work.
这就是为什么我觉得这是一个奇迹，因为是的，我觉得我得走了。你得走了。你得去完成你的工作，你梦想的工作。这真是太美妙了。得到了你们这些女孩的祝福，这真是太棒了，去年……哦，天哪，我等不及再次见到你们了，女孩们，这真的太美好了。哦，是的，我们会回来的。你们两个是天才，能遇到你们我感到非常荣幸。谢谢你们不可思议、鼓舞人心的工作。
Yes, thank you. All right. Ciao. Oh, my God, I'm trying again. I'm such a good. Ciao, go. Ciao, time. Lady, I cannot believe we got cut off
是的，谢谢。好的。再见。哦，天哪，我要再来一次。我太擅长这个了。再见，走吧。再见，拜拜。女士们，我简直不敢相信我们在她正要
right when she was going to tell us the story of becoming an actress. You know that was going to be a good story. Yeah. We have to invite her back for extended interview. I would love that. I want her in the studio for a full interview just from our brief time with her. She had so many good life stories. I know. And her character on the show is so much fun. She has like this especially fun storyline in episode four, like literally everything she was saying
给我们讲述她成为演员的故事时被挂断了。你知道那绝对是一个好故事。是的。我们得邀请她回来做一次加长版采访。我太乐意了。我希望她能来录音室进行一次完整的采访，仅仅从我们和她短暂的接触来看。她有太多精彩的人生故事了。我知道。而且她在剧中的角色太有趣了。她在第四集里有一个特别有趣的故事情节，字面意义上她说的每一句话
was making me laugh. Hilarious. I also need everyone to see her character's office. the amount of details and just the whole look of her office for the show, it's perfection. You do a whole breakdown for us. It's wonderful. Yeah, yeah. Well, everyone, we're getting close. It's just a couple weeks away. The paper premiering on Peacock, September 4th. All right, we'll see you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate
都让我笑个不停。太爆笑了。我还需要每个人都去看看她角色的办公室。办公室里的细节数量以及整个场景的视觉效果，简直完美。你得给我们做一次全面的剖析。太棒了。是的，是的。好吧，各位，我们快迎来首播了。只剩几周时间了。《The Paper》将于9月4日在 Peacock 首播。好吧，我们下周见。感谢收听《Office Ladies》。《Office Ladies》由 Audacy 出品，由珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fischer）和安吉拉·金斯利（Angela Kinsey）制作。执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯（Cassie Jerkins）。音频工程师是萨姆·基弗（Sam Kiefer），助理制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科（Ainsley Bubicoe）。Audacy 的执行制片人是莉亚·里兹·丹尼斯（Leah Reese Dennis）。《Office Ladies》由比尔·舒尔茨（Bill Schultz）混音和母带制作。主题曲是里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）的《Rubber Tree》。谢谢。本集尚无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。
producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
节目制作人是 Ainsley Bubicoe。Odyssey 的执行制作人是 Leah Reese Dennis。《Office Ladies》由 Bill Schultz 负责混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是 Creed Bratton 创作的《Ruppertree》。谢谢。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。